I think that this is uh is definitely
the most detailed example of something
major that went wrong in Harry and
William's relationship and of all the
things that Harry said about his family
obviously probably the most legitimate
of all the conversations about racism
but this is definitely up there as well
you know William physically assaulting
Harry is something that will probably
actually provoke sympathy from a lot of
people for Harry in a context where a
lot of people actually now in Britain
don't like him all that much
um but also I think you know it sounds
like he was genuinely really upset by
what happened
um there are possibly sometimes when
some of you know Harry he's somebody who
gets very angry about the big things but
he does sometimes sweat the small stuff
as well this is not a case of him
sweating the small stuff I think this
was a big major and very upsetting
incident in their relationship
um Harry's justification that he's doing
all of this and revealing all of this
stuff because his family was leaking to
the media about him might not land with
everybody
um after all you know like you say Henry
has definitely sort of defends his right
to privacy in the past but needless to
say I think we all do actually want to
know what went on here I certainly do
um and this is this is Harry moving from
a situation where a lot of the stories
he's told in the past have been half
told with names left out or you know we
know Harry was William was shouting and
screaming at Sandra he makes it
negotiations but we don't know what he
said at this time Harry has really gone
into concrete detail telling us specific
things that William said that upset him
I think if Harry maintains this policy
consistently throughout the book where
he's actually giving the full detailed
and I think it could actually wind up
swinging some public opinion back in his
favor favor I think one thing that
sometimes hurt Harry and Megan asked is
that they have claimed to have given
interpretation so they've said what they
think happened but they haven't really
told us why they think that you know
Harry said that this family was jealous
of him but he hasn't said how he knows
you know he hasn't told us I had a
conversation with William in which his
jealousy revealed itself because he said
X thing
um so if spare is the moment when Harry
finally goes beyond giving us an
interpretation into giving us really
Concrete Hard facts and detailed
accounts of what actually took place
then there is a possibility that this
could actually start to swing some
public opinion back in his favor
actually not coming out and commenting
on it has worked really well for the
royal family up until this point and the
one thing that has damaged William most
of all in this whole Saga was the point
at which he put his head above the
parapet and said that the Royals were
not a racist family and he said that on
video and so now any kind of allegation
you know we've had the stuff of the
Queen's leading waiting Susan Hussey
grinning a black charity bottom where
she was from anytime something like that
comes up it can be thrown back at
William you know you said the Royals a
lot of racist family but this instant
took place so I think we're will be
extremely cautious about addressing any
of this stuff head on